[Music]
Buhler hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to if you
haven't noticed I'm kind of a fan of
gravity falls yeah yeah yeah we got it
but who can blame me there's no bad
episodes of it the show about a boy and
girl who's been the summer with their
con-artists uncle in a supernatural town
has caught on like wildfire
there's cosplays fan art fan fiction
disturbing fan fiction the show is
touched a nerve with this hilarious
writing engaging story and unforgettable
characters
it's like Adventure Time meets x-files
there's no other show like it except
maybe if entertainment x-files
but together there's no doubt that this
show brings back the nostalgic feeling
of growing up in the 80s and 90s mix
with the technique and storytelling of
today's kids shows even if you're an
adult you feel like a kid watching
gravity falls and seeing how this is the
month of dark shadows
boo-ki creatures and things that go bump
in the night we're gonna look at the top
11 best episodes here today why top
eleven because grappling-hook
this is the top 11 best gravity falls
episode
number eleven sock opera maple comes
across yet another boyfriend she wanted
for her heart--it and it turns out he's
a puppeteer so she wants to put on her
own sock rock opera to win his attention
the downside is bill cipher the silliest
yet somehow also scariest creature
switches places with her brother dipper
and forces his body into that of a sock
puppet resulting in not only a ton of
funny imagery involving differs new form
alright it look it looks funny with your
bad but also a viewing of Mabel's
not-so-subtle opera trying to possess
the heart of another shallow FOP I'm
sorry Mabel but I have to go fight in
the war the songs are fun the suspense
is surprisingly intense and the idea is
perfectly ridiculous
this poster alone is enough to make the
episode worth it nothing more to say
except it'll definitely make you laugh
your socks off applause
[Applause]
number ten soos and the real girl
everyone can get sucked in too deep into
the digital realm but sometimes the
digital realm can get sucked in too deep
in dollars to soos is trying to work on
his love life and comes across a dating
simulator game the games character
giffany or as a Jif aney trains him to
go out on a date but then becomes too
obsessed and tries to date him in real
life sabotaging any chance he has for
real love the episode is great for
showing the pros of the online world but
also the dangers of becoming too
consumed by it since becomes too
invested in his false pixelated reality
but even when he tries to leave the
pixel a of reality that reality isn't
done with him wow that's awesome sort of
a red flag but mostly awesome it's a
real example but nevertheless it shows
how unhealthy and extreme lack of social
interaction mixed with engulfing
yourself in a fantasy world can go many
people online suffer with this kind of
dilemma and in so many various ways well
this is Souza's way and he shows that
you can start over again and make the
best of reality it just might take a few
pixelated hurdles to get through I'm
wrecking eye contact going on dates and
I haven't seen any natural sunlight for
13 hours
number nine Northwest mansion mystery
maples enemy Pacifica Northwest has been
described even by the show as a
one-dimensional character but that
suddenly changes when her family throws
a big party leaving all the riffraff out
leading to a ghost haunting the place
demanding that they be let in this is
one of the few times we see Pacifica and
dipper team up to fight the Menace
leading to a surprisingly sweet kind of
romance though they never become a
full-on couple these two share an
amazingly likable chemistry not just in
how well they work together but in his
as well as our understanding of what
Pacifica's upbringing is like there's a
seriously uncomfortable series of
sequences where her father rings a bell
whenever she disagrees with him and she
immediately silences herself like a dog
it's legitimately unnerving every time
it happens and it actually makes us feel
sorry for a character that seemed like a
comically simple antagonist on top of
that the episode is gorgeous with
popping colors heavy shadows and
visually strong layouts it matches to be
both funny and emotional over a
character many of us never thought we
would feel either for such a
stick-in-the-mud can suddenly be so
complex and interesting it teaches us
that underneath all that shallowness
there might be something more fragile
than we realized
number eight a tale of two stands so
much as Stan's background as a mystery
from where we grew up who we grew up
with and of course how honest he is so
much of his story as well as the story
of his family is finally shown here
proving to be both comic and tragic his
ability to both connect very well but
also be polar opposite with the ones he
loves most adds to the complexity of
what originally seemed like a
self-centered con artist but as the
previous episode on this list showed
everyone has a deeper side it's nice
seeing what made Stan who he is both
good and bad
this also starts the possibility of a
riff between dipper and Mabel wandering
their connection could be severed
similar to how Stan's was with his
family I don't know if this is good or
bad yeah you liked the way things were
here before seeing the parallels between
them in both how well they got along but
also on how distant they can choose to
be from each other it's hard not to get
emotionally invested in the future of
what may happen to them definitely more
of a serious episode but certainly has a
lot of laughs as well complex and
interesting with just the right amount
of laughs thrown in you stay away from
the kids I don't want them in danger
because as far as I'm concerned they're
the only family I have left
[Music]
number seven boys crazy with Izzy maple
my friends have tickets to see their
favorite boy band several times no like
that's our actual name several times
again with Izzy a popular inspection
they realize that they're not really
people at all well sorta they're
actually all clones so it's up to Mabel
to free them and show how they can live
in everyday life but will she be able to
give them up when the time comes
duper sweaters change every episode not
only does this one satirize the craze of
the boy bands perfectly but it even kind
of mocks the ones that Disney made as
well yeah I know it's supposed to be
more of an NSYNC Backstreet Boys kind of
thing but you know you get Jonas
Brothers out of this to Kemah you know
you're all thinking the idea of the band
being clones is clearly a commentary on
what many people have been saying for a
while about boy bands about how they're
all the same with a corporate mastermind
making only slight differences even with
all that said though it's surprisingly
never too mean-spirited the boys are
just products of the system they were
created in and they're still wide-eyed
and kind to anyone who wants to help
them out I think it would have been so
easy to go a meaner route especially
with some of the celebrities out there
but keep it innocent while still funny
they even got Lance Bass to do the voice
of all the clones that has to show this
is being done in some good spirit super
clever but not overly mean this is the
episode to win any vulnerable girl's
heart Mabel girl
[Music]
number since weirdmageddon to escape
from reality maple is easily a favor for
most people so it's no wonder that a
world completely ran and controlled by
her would be amazing to witness
technically a prisoner of bill cipher
maple has given her own reality that's
determined to make her happy so she'll
never want to leave it the world is
everything you would imagine Mabel would
create super Brides super silly totally
insane but also tons of fun they even
got a great cameo with Jon Stewart after
he left the Daily Show playing a strange
cat judge we are here to try to the
pines in the case of fantasy vs. reality
it's maples mind what do you expect the
episode also does well in rekindling
dipper and Mabel's fallen relationship
as they have to prove to each other the
importance each plays in their lives
this helps they add a little way to what
is an otherwise mad house of goofiness
one that like Mabel many of us would
never want to leave totally nuts but
also a hilarious adventure what else
would you expect from Mabel's mind this
world always knows what you want
sometimes even before you do
apparently I wanted a chinchilla number
five fight fighters all of us have
either played or seen someone else play
a popular fighting game whether it be
Street Fighter Mortal Kombat the Capcom
games and so forth well in this episode
all their blood hungry cheesiness is
brought to the limelight as one of
dippers games fight fighters is brought
to life when one of the characters
enters the real world that wants to fake
the world's greatest fight fighters take
me to the Soviet Union that's gonna be
tough for a number of reasons
everything about these awesomely corny
games of the past wreaks havoc on the
town and dipper tries to find a way to
stop him before he destroys everything
the winks and jabs and this are just as
funny as the well winks and jabs and the
original games they could only be done
by someone who loves this type of stuff
everything from the inability to hold
still they're bizarre need to beat up
cars and their talent of absorbing
items just by walking over half a taco
place it on before the animation style
the voice acting the attention to detail
is perfect you won't want a cheat code
to skip any of the comedy in this one I
said stay still this is as still as I
can stay number four Gideon rises this
was the end of the first season and by
god it feels like one hell of a big
ending different Mabel are forced to
leave gravity falls after Stan's mystery
shack is bought by their arch nemesis
Gideon Gideon doesn't find what he's
looking for though he builds a gigantic
version of himself to chase down dipper
and Mabel it's as epically silly as you
can get the fight sequence between the
three of them is so creative so large
but also so funny
you watched impress but also laughing at
the same time for a season that has such
great moments both in humor and in scope
this is an episode that brought it all
together it was a completely satisfying
climax to the first half of the show and
on top of that it has one of the biggest
cliffhangers ever we finally see what's
down stairs behind Stan's vending
machine it's finally revealed that he
knows more than he's letting on but how
much does he know and what will lead to
of course you have to wait until the
next season to find out what a finale
what an episode it's huge in all the
right ways now every summer we oh you
can't have this on Halloween Liz without
talking about the Halloween episode
gravity falls has a slight disadvantage
that talks about a lot of things
Halloween is yet it takes place over the
summer so how can you do a Halloween
episode well it turns out the
neighborhood loves Halloween so much
that they do it in the summer as well
and call it summer week it's mainly the
same except instead of jack-o'-lanterns
is Jackyl melons and it even comes with
its own scary story
the trickster haunts anyone who doesn't
have the summerween spirit and dipper
wants to skip out so he can go to a
party with Wendy it's up to the gang to
escape this evil entity while also
trying to keep the summerween spirit
alive almost any grab
befalls episode can be seen as the
Halloween episode so even more care had
to be taken to separate this from the
others and it totally pays off from the
costumes to the cheap novelties to the
traditions it still stands as a very
clear Sun up to the holiday it's a day
when the whole family can get together
at one place and celebrate what really
matters pure evil
I won't dare reveal the story behind
what the trickster is but let's just say
it's beyond clever and anyone who has
ever trick-or-treated before can
recognize and identify with it very
quickly with so many specials to watch
her on Halloween time this is a perfect
one to add to the list number two
weirdmageddon three take back the Falls
well of course the final episode would
make it out here it's everything the
show has been building up to and unlike
some other final episodes
it not only answers everything but it
delivers exactly what we've been looking
for the plot is very simple they have to
stop bill cipher from destroying the
world and that's about it but the
lengths they go to to make this battle's
epic creative smart and uproariously
funny completely pay off practically
every episode is building up to the end
of the world and this is pretty much how
the end of the world according to
gravity falls would go down by paying
homage to every other end of the world
from Mad Max to Walking Dead to the
majority of heavy metal covers it's
every over-the-top extreme you can
imagine but it also has the emotional
side it is the final episode so that
means every character has to say goodbye
and every one of them is given a
satisfactory exit it really takes its
time allowing you to let go of these
characters you share so many laughs and
adventures and it knows how to not go
return to King on us and not overstay
his welcome
it's about as perfect to send all for
the show as you can get bringing the
action the suspense and hilarity
what a way to end
and the number one gravity falls episode
is not what he seems you might be
wondering why I'm putting this one over
the final episode which seems so perfect
well on top of this one being the first
episode where gravity does fall and also
one of the biggest and most sought-after
reveals in the show's history this is
also the first time an episode made a
lot of their fans actually second-guess
themselves which for a TV show
especially a kids TV show it's very
difficult to do stain is arrested for
apparently not being who he says he is
we all know stand has done a lot of
wrong things in the past but as dipper
and Mabel dig deeper and deeper they
discover his lies are part of a web that
can never be untangled the stories just
get worse and worse and Stan isn't
really able to defend himself all he can
say is that you have to trust him you
have to trust him a wine he's used to
trick so many people before and with
everything that this episode throws at
us we find ourselves the audience having
a hard time trusting him - what's so
brilliant about this episode is that
completely makes us forget what's
obvious it's a main character in a kid
ship from Disney they once suddenly turn
in this unlikable or into a bad guy they
with yet another apocalyptic climax we
find the fate of everything rests in the
trust our characters have for their
uncle and one of them completely doesn't
trust him and the other wants to trust
him even she doesn't know if she can it
works because nothing but facts and
logic from the show's environment are
thrown at you which completely makes you
forget the facts and logic of your own
environment that Disney most likely
wouldn't go the path with this character
that you think they might go this sucks
you in so much that you completely
forget your better judgment and
completely get lost to what's going on
it's one of the few times so much of the
audience surrender themselves to the
show how do I know I'm not the only one
who went through this because the fan
art of one of the final scenes is
everywhere people remember this image of
Mabel holding her hands up because
people remember how torn they were at
this scene they were completely
withering questioning that trust which
makes the moment all the
more powerful it was one of the only
times most of us forgot we were watching
a show with focus groups strategic
writing and statistical choices and
became lost to the world and the
characters they presented us they were
real and we didn't know if we trusted
them and we feared someone would make
the wrong choice hell we feared if we
were in the situation we want make the
wrong choice
it's everything that made us realize why
it was so powerful in one single episode
help one single image it was when
stopped being a show for many of us and
became something much more real and much
more special other any that I missed
will leave them in the comments below
and explain why they're your favorite
hmm I feel we were talking so positively
for so long if there was a movie that
one of the actors from the show was in
that had a connection to Halloween and
somehow use the word bitch a lot in it
no no I got nothing no no
[Music]
[Applause]
coming next week as Freddy vs. Jason the
crossover we all thought we wanted to
see but you can see it now under vessels
ad free early access just three dollars
a month to see tons of people's videos
early as well as a bunch of other extra
features check it out and get the early
scoop
[Music]
Oh
you